a while back I did a video specifically
about trolley memes and ten was a nice
number to start with so I did ten
trolley memes it was fairly well
received and I've been meaning to do
another video discussing various
iterations on on this particular thought
experiment the pandemic crisis that
we're now living in caused by Co vid 19
or the corona virus has indeed provoked
a lot of people unsurprisingly to create
new trolley memes that have to do with
that so I thought I would do a roundup
of those with a little bit of commentary
so here we go before we get started of
course this picture that you're seeing
right here is the traditional trolley
meme thought experiment in which you see
a trolley going down the track it will
kill five people unless you flip the
switch which will result in at killing
one and there's various ways of
understanding this the memes that follow
represent ways of taking this particular
thought experiment and making it do
something else so here they are
this first meme of course deals with the
question of flattening the curve you see
a flatter curve and a steeper curve with
more bodies more people being killed by
the coronavirus trolley and the question
is whether we're going to flip the
switch and by that we would engage in
all the measures that have been
recommended for flattening that curve
with the second meme we see another
choice but now it's a landlord and for
the next few memes we're gonna see
people who have power people who can
make choices that determine other
people's choices and outcomes being the
ones who are depicted in this so we have
a landlord a tenant who just came back
from China in nowadays it could be
really any place where coronavirus is
breaking out like New York and the
question is whether you're going to risk
infection now who are you gonna risk
infection for the family of the people
or hundreds of other people and it
depends on whether you allow them to
stay or kick them out both of them seem
to be problematic but from a utilitarian
perspective it seems better to allow
somebody to stay now doesn't it
now if you thought the previous one was
dark take a look at this one you are the
leader of a country which is highly
dependent on tourism dollars and it
reads in the trolley as a year's worth
of tourists from kovat nineteen stricken
countries heading for your lovely
capital the bottom track has the five
percent oldest population of your
country with weak immune system the
lever redirects tourist trolleys this
one and every single one after it back
to their country of origin the top track
however has a bag with a percentage of
your GDP equal to a year of your
country's tourism revenue will you pull
the lever so now it's between old
immune-compromised people's lives and
tourism dollars and now you know this is
one where you could say well that's an
easy decision to make of course we
should protect the old people but a
government is posed with some serious
issues particularly the more dependent
they are upon those tourism dollars as a
significant part of their GDP and
therefore part of their tax structure
Meem number four depicts a situation
that perhaps corresponds better to our
American situation in which some people
within the government have been saying
that it's very important that we protect
the economy above all and that some
older people some people at risk would
be willing to sacrifice themselves in
order for the economy to continue to
grow or at least not be as damaged as
much I particularly like this
formulation of the problem because it
kind of shows that if you do sacrifice
people for the economy what's the net
result going to be you're gonna ruin the
economy anyway as a result
here's another and perhaps darker
interpretation it reads you can stop the
trolley at any time but doing so would
disrupt the trolley service causing the
company to lose profits and so there's
no alternatives here other than whether
you flip the switch or not what this
represents is a view of the government
as really much more interested in
corporations than in protecting the
public which is a real failure and you
know it's a debatable issue I think that
you know the federal government of
America at this time and some of the
state governments could in fact be
rightly charged with having that
motivation and that prioritization of
large corporations over the welfare of
human beings
Meem number six is along the same lines
and I think this is perfectly framed for
those who are engaging in that line of
we've got to put the economy first which
really means not just putting the entire
economy but putting the sectors of the
economy that they favor first this is
from Bob Paxton he wrote aha now I get
it
America is doing the trolley problem but
some want to save the trolley and
there's two ways of thinking about this
one would be saying that the executive
here in America and also in our states
and in some of them and the legislators
are fundamentally mistaken in their
priorities about what they actually care
about this would be reading them as if
they were in some respect ignorant or
misguided we could also have a less
benign interpretation where we say you
know the trolley is it's a lousy health
care system in which insurance companies
have been allowed to dominate for a very
long time and for-profit medicine as in
effect displaced more publicly minded
medical centers and procedures those
would be the trolley that is going to be
running people over not just the virus
but a system that ought to be able to
but won't be able to protect people and
heal people from the virus
here's another meme I came across that
is smaller scale and a bit more oriented
at just being funny rather than making a
deep dark social policy point the lever
has a spittle from AK Ovid 19 patient do
you wash your hands before touching your
face what if it's like really annoying
it's kind of an absurdist thing because
you could easily you know whether you
wash your hands before touching your
face doesn't mean that you can't flip
the lever and save the people I think
it's simply pointing out how ridiculous
some of the things that we feel
discomforted or annoyed by are when it
comes to protecting ourselves and
protecting others
here's another one coming directly from
the Facebook page for trolley problem
memes saying we all need to do our part
to flatten the curve so please when
tying victims to the tracks
remember to space them at least six feet
apart so that our imaginary people and
the trolley problem aren't going to get
Co vid 19 and die of that rather than
dying of the trolley running them over
this is actually quite a good one as
well and I I don't see how anyone could
get offended at that unless they were
just simply choosing to take offence
because after all these are completely
imaginary people aren't they
now this meme and the one that follows
are not simply about the
coronavirus or covet 19 pandemic but
things that apply to trolley problems in
general and how they would fit in with
life and and I think this is a great one
there's us imagining the trolley problem
where we have agency but really the
trolley problem is more likely to be
about some other schmuck at the the helm
who and were stuck there on the tracks
in some place and we hope that he makes
the right decision
and here's the final meme in this series
another one having to do with the
conditions of trolley problems when we
see them in application and in this case
we actually do have some agency but it's
not a nice clean clearly delineated
problem as the thought experiment makes
it out to be
agency in real life ethical
decision-making is always messy and it
can often be screwed up by what other
people are doing or have decided to do
in the past and maybe didn't tell us
about all sorts of other conditions can
apply
I would like to close by pointing out
this image to you and this is indeed
another meme coming from the trolley
problem memes page and I think this one
is great it's a excellent reminder for
what we all ought to be doing now and it
may indeed feel like an absurd endless
task pushing this trolley up the the
hill and the trolley again could not
just be Kovan but also the system that
allowed this to get as bad as it is the
reference of course is to the Greek hero
or if you like tragic villain Sisyphus
who is condemned to push this boulder up
the hill for all eternity who Camus
takes as a symbol and as a possibility
for all of us in his book the myth of
Sisyphus and the message is it may seem
too much for us it may seem that we
don't make any progress but we have to
keep on plugging away and this is a
great place to talk about something else
that Camus thought was really important
and it's this that even in a world that
might in fact be absurd we can still
have dignity and not just dignity but
decency and we can exhibit a kind of
solidarity with other people and we do
that today by observing the protocols
that have been recommended to us in this
crisis
you